we could see a very big shake up this
weekend in the way Democrats choose
their presidential candidates for more
than 50 years now it's worked like this
the road to the nomination has started
with the caucuses in Iowa and then
there's New Hampshire's first in the
nation primary well President Biden
wants to change that and some Democrats
do not like the idea at O'Keefe traveled
to New Hampshire where primary voters
could soon lose a great deal of clout
and prestige
the Red Arrow Diner in downtown
Manchester New Hampshire is known for
its food and is a must stop for any
presidential candidate you have to walk
through these doors in order to get into
that Oval Office but co-owner Amanda
wibby worries that might change
Democrats go through with a plan to drop
the granite state as their first primary
every four years they descend upon us
and I think a lot of people customers
would be disappointed but what was taken
from us Democrats are set to approve a
new calendar Saturday that moves South
Carolina's primary to the front followed
by a combo of New Hampshire and Nevada
three days later Battlegrounds Georgia
and Michigan would also move up while
Iowa is being pushed farther back all
right let's take a look at our returns
this is especially stinging to New
Hampshire which has held the first
primary since the 1920s Bill Clinton
didn't win here and yet New Hampshire
tonight has made Bill Clinton The
Comeback Kid
16 years later Hillary Clinton did win
the state after tearing up on the
campaign trip you still want to see us
fall backwards but Joe Biden placed
fourth in 2020 and now is arguing change
is overdue this proposal by President
Biden will reflect the strength of
America's greatest
asset
and that is our diversity the argument
is New Hampshire with just over a
million residents is too small Rural and
white not reflective of the changing
country New Hampshire Democratic party
chairman Ray Buckley strongly disagrees
we are supportive of diversity across
the country we are we are not opposed to
bringing in other states but the fact is
that New Hampshire is going to be the
first and New Hampshire Senator Gene
Shaheen warns the changes could upset
voters in her swing state and cost
Democrats votes in November in 2000 Al
Gore would have been president without
Florida if he had won New Hampshire and
he came within just a thousand a few
thousand votes of winning New Hampshire
New Hampshire takes the primary so
seriously it even has a state law
requiring its primary be the first in
the nation National Democrats want that
law dropped but Republican Governor
Chris sununu who's also thinking about
running for president says that won't
happen it's an absolute joke it's not
based on anything to ensure that the
voters in America will have a better
first filter it's just based on a
personal preference of a candidate back
at the red arrow Manchester residents
Stu holzhauser thinks the proposed
change is foolish I like it being first
I think it's good for the state I think
it is a good reflection of the country
but his brother Bill visiting from North
Carolina takes a different view if the
objective is to get a more uh diverse
perspective in that first uh tranche of
states that go then a different approach
might be worn
President Biden and vice president
Harris will be here in Philadelphia
today to meet with the Democratic
National Committee before they hold that
vote on the primary calendar tomorrow of
course New Hampshire could still go
first and the party could punish them
taking away their delegates to the 2024
convention this this kind of an academic
exercise however because remember we're
anticipating the president will run for
reelection won't face any major primary
Challenger and there's a clause in this
new plan they can revisit it all in four
years and redraw the calendar yet again
Tony yeah but it does matter to us
journalists the last time I covered a
primary in New Hampshire I interviewed
voters while ice fishing and I don't
believe they have that activity in South
Carolina and personally I'm okay with
that
thanks a lot we know you'll be on top of